this is coach schnoop's pep talk  pittsburgh steelers  gather around  i want to talk to you guys for a minute  we're damn near done with the season and  there's still some hope  you guys got to pull together  fight for each other  ben stop watching mash  get you some sleep  get you some rest  defense tighten up on your backstroke  i want you on the super bowl man i'm  performing i want y'all to be there with  me can y'all do that for me coach mike  tomlin you may have to fire a few people  it is what it is  let's make this thing happen super bowl  2022 i'll be performing will you be  there with me  let's go stellars  let's go  all right i'm joining snoop's  pep talk but my pep talk is for my  chicago bears  please  please get an offensive line  that's it  [Laughter]  hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for  watching make sure to hit subscribe for  the latest news and highlights from nbc  sports